elles ont entre 20 et 40 ans elles ont
promené des pères tranquilles et leur
famille elles ont connu la guerre et les
maquis de la résistance elles ont été
pendant quelques années la voiture
préférée des gangsters
ce sont les tractions avant un jour
elles ont disparu mais on ne les a
jamais vraiment oublié en 1968 même
quelques passionnés ont fondé le club de
l'attraction universelle un club qui
prouve aujourd'hui 300 adhérents
certains citoyens liste possède qu'une
véritable flotte de 7 11 ou 15 qu'ils
sont allés dénicher souvent au fond
d'une grange ou leurs anciens
propriétaires les avaient remises et des
poussières et repeindre est visé elles
connaissent aujourd'hui une seconde
jeunesse
même si certaines d'entre elles ont plus
de cent cinquante mille kilomètres au
compteur
je recherche des relations anciennes
c'est surtout le blog gérard c'est à
dire la voiture tout le monde même de
mes paquets les collectionneurs parce
que par exemple des berlines traction ça
tout le monde dort là je trouve que la
pièce unique par exemple et celle là
c'est un coupé oui c'est un coupé
combien d'exemplaires y at il
actuellement de couper en france alors
on a fait une sorte de recensement nous
ne trouve une quarantaine actuellement
aucun plaisir à conduire une voiture
moderne vous n'êtes pas maître de votre
voiture c'est la voiture qui vous
conduit tandis que ces voitures là vous
vraiment vous fait corps avec la voiture
et vous l impression presque 2 mètres
avec un animal que vous recommander
est-ce que l'animal se cabre de temps en
temps ah oui oui très souvent et
s'installer par quoi une bonne dose de
philosophie faut pas avoir peur de
tomber en panne en pleine nuit avec
la panne que personne n'est capable de
vous dépanner quoi les jumelages sont
d'origine
oui ce sont les immigrés sa dépression
c'est une
s'est penché sur le carburateur stadium
va vous êtes c'est l'airé ça marche
moins vite mais quand vous marchent au
ralenti sur glace mars plus vifs ce qui
au départ est une passion peut se
transformer en bonnes affaires pendant
plusieurs années une voiture perd de sa
valeur
lorsqu'elle est assez ancien pour entrer
dans la catégorie 10
quitter alors sa cote remonte pour
atteindre des proportions considérables
on peut que la mode remettent la voiture
au goût du jour à sa sortie en 1937 ce
coupé valait 27 mille francs actuels
l'année dernière il en valait 8000 cette
année il vaut plus cher qu'à sa sortie
contenu avec celle là avec je sors dans
paris je suis sûr et par étaient deux ou
trois fois dans la rue par quelqu'un qui
veut soit me l'acheter soir qui me dit
ah j'avais cette voiture là quand
j'étais jeune mon père avait ces
voitures là on est très très bien vu
parler
et et france de police et je dois dire
que vous avez constaté qu'il y avait
plus d'indulgence à leur égard pour la
circulation ils sont très intelligents
sion on oublie mais sans clignotant ou
si on projet n'est pas un embouteillage
et bien il faut faciliter la tâche
cette indulgence c'est sans doute le
privilège de large
[Musique]